I knew you were at the Golden Globes
Allison Janney was here and she told
this really funny story he's such a
great actor she's terrific but a great
girl
she Allison Janney's told me this great
story if she was hanging out with Tonya
Harding I went to the Golden Globes and
Tonya Harding just kept saying oh this
woman's been taking wonderful care of me
getting me through the red carpet
helping me find my seat and everything
and then she pointed you and went oh
there she's like that Sharon Stone you
took care of Tonya Harding at the Golden
Globe my son and I did we were there's a
certain point in when you're coming in
where they take the presenters and the
nominees and you go through this kind of
shoot where you have to sign the wall
from the globin globes of the year and
then you come up these little stairs
that are about half as wide as the
staircase here in the studio and then
you go up and there's a wall of press I
mean there's hundreds of photographers
but and we were coming around to go up
the stairs and I felt this woman behind
me uncomfortable and there's a lot of
stars yeah in the line and I saw this
woman that I didn't recognize and she
was just flipping she was really scared
and I was like hey hi how are you what's
your name what are you doing she's like
I'm Tonya Harding and I was like oh wow
hi yeah great she's like I'm just so
nervous sure and I was like well geez
you certainly don't have anything to be
nervous about you're the kind of
champion they make movies about and then
the people in the movies get nominated
for these big awards right why are you
nervous why don't you come ahead and my
son was like oh man you're so amazing
and he loved the movie and was telling
her how great the movie was so we had
her go in the line in front of us and
I'm like I've got your back and then she
was nervous going up the stairs about
how to take her gown you know and I'm
like just put your bag onto your arm and
take your dress and we got her to the
top of the stairs and she looked at me
and I'm like just look down that camera
lens like you're looking at a triple
axel yes there isn't one of them that
can do that do you provide this service
for everybody
if you're going to an award show in your
nervous contact 1-877-748-1018 in our
NGO said that woman right this woman
right yeah yeah yeah yeah it was really
sweet
you